voilà donc deux requins du studio
dreamworks en salle 13 octobre ooyala
ordinaire l'ancienne c'est la poisse
sionisation du monde a scotché tout le
monde
il s'est passé quoi j'ai pensé du monde
j'ai arrêté ah non c'est vrai qu'ils ont
dessiné tous les personnages en fonction
des acteurs c'est la première fois
qu'ils font savoir à quoi il ya scorsese
on voit un peu sa tête
oui ce messin forcément il ya jack black
je me connais ouais et voila quoi ils
ont tous la tête de poisson
voilà c'est poids smith voilà alors
comme tous les grands comiques
vous allez remonter sur scène parce que
vous tenez à garder le contact avec la
scène avec le public cette proximité
vous fait du bien
elle vous enrichissez proximité la
tabbee enrichi je comprends plus c'est
toi qui répond non c'est à dire que au
cinéma on est un petit peu logique
cinéma après sam et neuf mois pour la
voir au théâtre elle est là tout chemin
voilà c'est à dire qu'au cinéma
ils en ont fait une vanne andy lui ne
vais pas m'arrêter là
c'est au cinéma onf et une bannière
ressort neuf mois plus tard et alors que
sur scène on fait la vanne la réaction
elle est immédiat voilà et voilà donc on
est payé tout de suite par le rire du
public et celle médulien voilà les aime
c'est bizarre c'est que quand on a fait
notre premier spectacle avant d'arriver
à l'olympia on l'avait joué des tas de
fois et donc la vanne tu as le temps de
la travailler je sais comment l'amener
et là c'est la première fois c'est notre
deuxième spectacle d'un côté où on écrit
dans notre bureau et on va tout de suite
les gens vont regarder un bureau dans le
bureau ouais mais ça faisait un
comptable c'est pas con ça il faudrait
qu'on en prenne un ton et un comptable
pour conter quoi et millions qui est
sacré will smith
vous aviez un pourcentage sur double
zéro oui vous êtes riche
je souhaite une notion relative
un des pans stade la famille ou passer
des postes et généreux ou par
l'entourage du club non ça va quand même
on s'achète des fringues en commun voilà
est ce que est ce que comme tous les
grands comiques vous êtes sinistre dans
la vie alors étrangement on est les
scènes comiques au monde à être géniaux
même dans la vie c'est ce qu'on me dit
elle c'est en ça dort on est comme dans
la vie comme dans la scène
monsieur est ce que comme tous les
grands comiques j'espérais faire un film
dramatique
certainement pas pour l'instant non
voilà enfin nos films comiques que les
gens jugeront dramatiquement bravo et
normalité bien je vous en ferai d'autres
durant l'interview est ce que comme tous
les gros tonique un jour unique créé
tout le monde avec un césar c'est pas
notre ambition commune ambition
vêtements faut faire marrer les gens
savent maintenant comique ouais moi
c'est un appareil cette volonté du césar
forcément ouais enfin c'est bien si
enfin on est dans un autre truc vraiment
préparé un petit discours buhot busson
visent l'oscar donc ouais l'oscar on ira
à dakar est ce que comme tous les grands
comiques savuka ses couilles québec qui
disent ah t'es marrant toi vas-y fait de
nourrir
généralement le tabac celui-là on a des
réactions je le paye assez un ou deux
comme ça et des gosses en plus
est ce que comme tous les grands
comiques vous détestez les autres comics
on est dedans on a des très bons amis
très bohème et jamel gad des familles
comique et nous on fait parti de pas
trop de familles en fait j avec fred
d'omar jamel voilà vous êtes heureux
tous les deux très bien
jamais un problème entre vous jamais
aucune rumeur jamais jamais aucune
rumeur de sa répartie en a pas je suis
ce problème en france à moi vous aurez
jamais vraiment n'est pas david charvet
qui veut monsieur nommé monsieur quand
tu me suit david charvet physiquement
regarde quel pardo thiery excuse moi je
disais que jamais jamais de problème
entre vous jamais l'ombre d'une rumeur
de séparation
ça fait beaucoup de mal quand même shark
tale dans notre couple un donc de
requins ouais ouais ouais j'avais
environ 400 phrase de plus à dire que
lui vous n'avez 4 forcément c'est un
petit problème interne qu'on a n'a pas
été très loin
non ça va franchement une bonne bagarre
là dessus ça résout tout quoi on se
bagarre sans donner les coups sont
portés l'équipe mais on se bagarre
vraiment vous vous séparez jamais in
charles la lundi la cote